it's time for a tease social study your  quick look at what the stars are posting  online it's child and big sister and  Savannah's husband  Savannah Guthrie's hubby and kids that  crashed the today set Friday morning the  show shared these sweet family portraits  on Twitter wall Sofia Vergara snapped  some sweet and silly shots of the Modern  Family cast wrapping up season 8  then there's Bethenny Frankel with a TBT  featuring Kim Kardashian Britney Spears  putting on a personal fashion show for  her fans and blac chyna showing off her  post-baby weight loss with this  before-and-after so yeah finally former  couple Tarek and Christina el Moussa  goofing off on set of their HGTV show  flip flop another open house on flip or  flop oh we got action shots over here  you